I wanted to give a lecture kind of on
forcing moves and initiatives so first
of all can anyone tell me what a forcing
move is yes right
you're basically attacking something
usually right or checking them or doing
something what's the power of a forcing
move Yeah right then you don't have to
worry about oh they can just play
whatever they want they have a very few
they're very few options so you're kind
of controlling the action controlling
the game now sometimes for example if
you to play a lot of forcing moves out
of the opening it means that you get to
attack a lot of their pieces it means
that you know you get to develop your
pieces with gain of time and time is
something I think that in a chess game
people forget about you know they don't
think of time as a factor but for
example if you can get out four pieces
to your opponent's one that's a big time
advantage right cuz you have all these
pieces out and they don't have them out
yet and this next game illustrates is
very well so how many of you know who
Paul Morphy is very good he was he was
your basically considered widely
considered just the best player in the
world you should buy even quite a ways
you know around mid 1800s now if he were
to play today he probably would maybe be
master strength but for that time and
considering no one ever taught him like
you guys are being taught now or you
know have been for chess it's really
quite amazing then he got to the lovely
got and his games are actually very
useful because at that time a lot of
players just took material so for
example if you're their opponents
offered that material they take and
normally that's a good policy but he was
very good at finding forcing moves
and you know he didn't mind giving up
material for the initiative so before we
stop the game actually can anyone tell
me what the initiative is because that's
kind of the key to this game it's not
easy to explain the way I would describe
it is it basically means you're forcing
action so if you're the one playing lots
of forcing moves and your opponent's
defending you have the initiative and
it's usually very important if you can
maintain it if you can keep the
initiative and not give it up it's
usually a very good thing for you and
this game white took the initiative
basically on move three and didn't give
it up for the whole game so that's kind
of what happened here so um let's start
the game so II 4/5 native three queen up
six how many of you like this move I
don't like it either can anyone tell me
why blue shirt yeah very good so the
queen is a little bit exposed here the
King a little bit but the Kings not so
bad but I would say that the Queen's a
little bit exposed so almost always
you'd rather not get out your queen
early you'd rather defend the palm of
the night with the pawn bring this
Knight out
incidentally you'd almost never ever
want to defend with your F pawn very bad
idea and in this case believe it or not
there's a sacrifice that's actually
quite strong and black ends up getting
either attacked heavily or giving up
there look like this so do not bring
your f pound out early almost always a
bad idea
alright so Queen f6 was played white
developed so the knight might come here
black didn't want that they played here
so from this point on basically white
takes the initiative and never lets it
go the rest of the game so every single
move from here on out for the most part
is an attacking
move which is rather impressive it's
very rare that you can maintain an
initiative for that long but one of the
things morphe was great at and what we
can learn from is that he was really
great at taking initiative and just
never giving it up and always attacking
his opponent so first he played this
move and black recaptures so first quiz
for you guys what most would you
consider here yeah Bishop g5 it's a
great move to consider I like how just
because your opponent took your pawn you
didn't automatically assume you had to
recapture like a lot of people would you
wanted to counter-attack the Queen the
one drawback I'd say the Bishop g5 is
that the Queen would move and now this
bishops the Knights kind of tied to the
bishop now so you could play Queen takes
pawn and I think your position is very
good Bishop g5 I think should be a fine
move but it wasn't what was played he
played a similar move and he won't have
any ideas besides you yeah
the other bishop could move but then the
knight would simply be taken so I'd say
that you don't want to give black an
opportunity to take your piece okay what
other attacking move do you have besides
Bishop g5 very nice the Queen's exposed
right so you move the pawn up to attack
the Queen very nice so the Queen moves
so question now is do you take back this
pump
yeah
very nice he still doesn't want this
pawn now quintics d4 is a perfectly good
move if a student of mine were to show
me this game that I get but Queen takes
d4 head it's a good job good move and
we'd move on but again more if he hated
to give up the initiative he always
wants to be attacking every move
but his opponent was like well what are
you doing then let me take your pawn for
free but this moves very risky because
why does all these pieces up right so
what is why play this moves pretty easy
yeah I don't know about that move
because then I take your rope remember
your rooks attacked you don't want to
give up your rope
look at you one yep so the Queen is
under attack it only has one square so
now what
Bishop f5 looks like a nice move but
there's a big drawback to this can you
figure out what it is
yeah so be careful before you suggest
the move make sure your piece can't just
be captured for free right and this goes
when you're playing a game it's so nice
to want to be able to attack stuff but
make sure your opponent can't just
capture a valuable piece of yours taking
the g2 pawn is annoying but it opens up
your room right it gives your get your
rook out and it's just a pawn a pawn is
not nearly as nice all right
rook g3 looks like a good move to me
let's play Queen move back
yep very nice don't want to give up that
initiative right but now what there are
by the way keep in mind just because not
all of his moves are necessarily the
only good ones so if you suggest the
movement it wasn't played don't think oh
I got it wrong think male well maybe
mine was good too yep that's the move I
like because it cuts off the options the
Queen would have to move back here which
looks like an awful square right because
you're walking into a potential
discovered attack but morphe ended up
choosing this one but I like your move
better
so Queen moves back now finally finally
white takes this pawn after all that but
what's the difference why didn't what
did we gain by delaying the capture
other than losing his Jeep on what an
white game yes
development right White's so well
developed now the Knights are out the
rooks out this Bishop can get out very
easily blacks pieces are all sitting at
home twiddling their thumbs
not exactly what black wants to be doing
black wants to be getting pieces out
right and because he's being attacked
every move he can't just give up a queen
right so every movie has to move his
queen and a la white to keep it time
this is why the initiative and forcing
moves are so important because you don't
give your opponent a chance to catch up
with you to get out there pieces to do
what they want to do and it's why you
really want to you know if you can take
the initiative it can be such an
important thing
so black retreated the Queen so now what
yeah and up five I like this move a lot
it would allow Queen takes e5 check but
I think that this looks very risky y
could play just visually three for
example or Bishop e2 and I don't know I
mean I'd say with the the discovery is
possible nineteen to g7 check is a
threat I'd say that white blacks
position is very risky so I like Knight
f5 a lot it's not what was played though
this was the one move where he didn't
make a huge threat he didn't make a
threat actually but he didn't make a
huge threat
yep
Bishop c4 looks like a nice move to me
but he didn't play but again I'd say
good move just not his choice he wanted
to I this week square see how that
square it looks kind of juicy just kind
of weak pawn attacking it yeah you're
very excited when I'm in Reno Bishop f4
looks like a nice move to me it defends
the pawn eyes the square not when he
played yep very nice his idea is that he
wants a ninety six check very tempting
right so his opponent should really try
to be developing something but instead
he keeps attacking so actually more fees
next move is probably not a good one but
it is kind of continuing with the theme
of the game curious what you guys would
play yeah
this is actually what I think is the
best move the night goes to d6 check the
king would have to go here and then you
could do all sorts of things Bishop to
c4 a move like this looks real tempting
attacking f7 you have all sorts of good
moves
I like your move the best but he played
I think a worse one Knight f5 which
looks like a great move and it turned
out really well but actually it's kind
of interesting and when I shown this
game before and I never pointed this out
because I wanted the game to have a nice
flow to it
but one of the things you'll notice even
when you check out really games of
really strong players they all make
mistakes right do you never want to
assume that all their moves are perfect
or all their moves are Oh must be the
best in any move I come up with ask the
viewers
I think meta fuds a mistake question is
why yep the pawn could take a rope but I
would hardly call it flip free because
your queen is hanging so rook yes free
no there's a very steep price to that
rook very few people could afford a rook
like that anyone else now what is the
venom of this lecture would you say
attacking and forcing moves does black
have a horse and move of his own yes
what's most forcing like when you're I
say forcing moves what's the first thing
that popped in mind captures and what
else what else is really forcing yeah
checks so always look do I have any
checks does my opponent have any checks
if your opponent plays a check and you
didn't see it it means you didn't think
long enough on your previous move
because you never ever want to miss if
your opponent can put you in check so
does black have a check here yup not
what was played Queen before check and
this move would have been a nasty shock
to Morphy who was otherwise playing a
great game because not only is it a
check it's and people who attended my
lecture just now she'd know what this is
what is this a fork so it's not only a
check it's a fork now what can get out
of this fork by playing the knight back
but now black can simply take this rogue
now it wouldn't surprise me because
black
White's positions so good it wouldn't
surprise me if there's some magical
solution but this would have been a
pretty big missed right so you see how
even someone as strong as more free can
make mistakes and play you know slightly
careless moves
so Knight of five I don't think was the
best move but his opponent didn't catch
it play Queen e6 so lesson you can learn
also from this is that no matter how
ugly your position looks no matter how
bad you think things are even strong
opponents can mess up but you have to
make sure you get that chance because
after this one move this one mistake
black never ever gets a chance to get
back in the game and from here on out he
plays a really wonderful game so what
does he play not yeah
Bishop c4 I think is a really nice move
now what he played there's a cool trick
with Bishop c4 what happens if I take
your Bishop right and notice how it's a
nice fork right the only reason I'd say
he who didn't play Bishop c4 is cuz then
there's maybe this move and that could
be annoying because now there's no on
passant because Queen takes Knight check
or even Queen takes Bishop now because
maybe actually no Queen takes Bishop
there's a pawn in the way but you can
get rid of your pawn and then your
knight has d six kind of clever huh but
okay Queen takes Knight check could be
annoying but yeah after g5 takes and you
could play Knight d6 check and it's
probably still decent but I think why
play this lightly marker any guesses
it's a very direct move nothing too fast
yeah
rook takes g7 is nice because if Bishop
takes Knight takes Czech that's your
idea right however you never want to
assume my my old teacher used to be very
hard on me for this because he called
this wishful thinking analysis he'd say
well you want your opponent to take your
rook so you're assuming they're gonna do
it but let's say black says well I don't
want to take your rook I'm gonna take
your knight
oh now you have a rook attacked you of a
knight attack things are not so easy
right so you want to avoid engaging in
wishful thinking analysis make sure your
opponent is forced to do what you want
them to do don't assume they're gonna
walk down your path yep which one it's
hard to choose between Knights usually
yeah I think he put that five one and I
think the reason is cuz after this move
this pawn is still hanging whereas after
this move the rook defense see that so I
think his move is slightly more accurate
but that's how you choose between them
it's usually very subtle things but it's
not easy it's the same thing say you
have to move a rook to the open file
which one do you choose it's a really
hard decision and it just takes a lot of
practice and usually you use logic like
in this case again the logic is while my
rook wants to defend the pawn so black
took white took with what Bishop no what
did white take with white takes back the
bishop right well pawn remember you have
a rook King doesn't do well to forget
about this so you take me what very good
good still check what
yeah
so rook takes g7 again looks like a
logical move right but what happens
after Queen takes e5 check I hit your
rope enough and your king there's a fork
but yeah this is a fork correct and
you're in check so you don't have time
to play Knight takes pawn and fork me
yeah so again make sure you're not
allowing your opponent to do anything
that they want to do make sure that you
have their threats cover but do you have
any temple moves do you have attacking
moves to get stuff out for free yes
great so it's a temple move right it
forces so black would love to take your
rope right but it can't because the
Queen's attacked already the Queen the
bishop is defended by the knight the
pawns defended by the rook so black
really doesn't have any great moves
so we tried Queen to e7
now what yep
right because now the Knights defended
by the bishop right and notice that once
again black doesn't get a single move to
do what he wants to do he's just
responding to everything the more he
does so the King moves to c7
now what
yep
very nice move so one of the things is
when you're attacking do you usually
want to trade Queens no right because if
you trade Queens when you're attacking
it usually makes your attack less strong
but Queens your best attacking piece but
in this case morphine has something very
specific in mind those Queens d6 check
so black takes the queen now he would
capture us with what yep pawn so is the
checkmate
it's close king can escape so now what
orange shirt
that would be a perfectly good move
you're taking a rope you're threatening
to take the night but remember more if
he has the initiative right he doesn't
want to give up his initiative he wants
to keep attacking
so rook b5 is possible however I hope
you have an idea after pawn takes rook
remember make sure your opponent can't
capture you right one of the number one
rules yeah very nice so the king is
running out of squares right it's only
move is pawn to c5
now what yeah very good
so if black tries King c6 why that's a
very nice move
Superman it's alright yep very good and
that is that's a pretty cool checkmate
huh now here's another common mistake
people make they think 95 is also check
me but what's the problem now yeah
you're blocking your own piece this is a
very very common mistake when people not
necessarily on this move but when people
are calculating ahead they miss that
their own pieces can block one another
so make sure you don't make the same
mistake make sure you're really focused
and make sure you're aware of what
pieces are blocking what so 98 is a
pretty that's a pretty cool checkmate
huh that would have been a nice way to
end of the game I think but black opted
to play this move instead so now all
these threatening moves right here white
finds a really nice way to end the game
yep
palm before is a very tempting move ah
so what do you do after King a for run
run run away Forrest Gump has nothing on
this King ah yeah I don't know maybe you
have a way to checkmate here you could
play Bishop check so if the King moves
back here I'm pretty sure you should
have made check ha this is cool so if
King here there's there's a mate again
right so you have check check and then
what's the final checkmate yeah yeah
that would be pretty cool
yeah Bishop d5 fails to 96 but 98 so
cool checkmate um well I don't see a
checkmate here at least not immediately
now I could very well be missing it
because this is a weird position you can
check here check here but somehow this
silly King it's hard to check mate isn't
it now I don't doubt there is one but I
do it at ease don't see it so yeah I'm
pretty sure there isn't me but uh yeah I
know watch this is great this is totally
unnecessary
so King here right so take my rook pawn
up so I'm threatening Bishop g4
checkmate see that it's got to take my
other rook and then I play King here now
I'm turning this checkmate so he brings
his rook over now I threaten this
checkmate any losses
I made all that up it could be wrong
that's a pretty cool checkmate though
huh never ever do this by the way just
win easily
no don't don't make your life hard so he
actually won in two moves rather than
this but you have to admit though the b4
b5 check makes pretty cool huh morphe
wishes he could have checked made it
that way but he found a simpler way yeah
sorry
Bishop to e3 so that's indeed a check
and what happens if I take your room
remember one of the thin keys is if you
check your opponent always make sure
they can't take your checking piece if
they can take the piece that's checking
then they get it a check right so be
very careful more if you found a quiet
move now when you're attacking usually
you want to play forcing attacking moves
right that's usually the way you go but
sometimes a little a quietly now I
wouldn't call this move quiet because it
does threaten checkmate but it's a
subtle move a move of which doesn't take
anything doesn't check anything but
threaten makes a threat that just cannot
be stopped
yes a4 so a4 threatens B for checkmate
is that your idea that looks like a very
good move um it's okay let's say I play
a Knight to c6 I'm gonna try to stay
alive here
Fiji's stuff
nevermind wrong crowd maybe c3
threatening b4 that's a cool checkmate
I like your checkmate a lot he found a
much simpler one though so these two
bishops do a beautiful job right to keep
this pin pick King pinned along the edge
so all you have to do is what I think
you got it now oh yeah they're very nice
so it's a subtle move right but it gets
the rook four up under the attack and
now rook a3 that's checkmate right how
does black stop it
if you can't find it you're not doing
anything wrong there's no way to stop it
do you see a way to stop that's true
resigning is a sure way to stop your
opponent from checkmate again but in
this case he played b5 and now the
checkmate everyone okay three and that
ends the game so what did we learn from
this game can anyone tell me a few
things of them the fact that morphe was
a really cool chess player what else do
we learn a lot of if you want to look
for cool check mending patterns
check out more of these games he did a
lot of them part of it's because his
opponents we're not nearly as good as
him at least a lot of them weren't so a
lot of his games end in really brutal
checkmates which are very cool these
days it's harder to get a checkmate like
that because opponents resign and
because people are in general a little
bit stronger now yep very right he was
the best player of his time and by quite
a ways but even he made mistakes right
he missed Queen before check good up in
anyone now maybe it was a blitz game
maybe his opponent was so much weaker he
was you know talking to someone having a
drink while playing his game who knows
but probably he just missed it Queen
before check easy move to miss so make
sure that you're always on the lookout
for your opponent's ideas no matter how
bad their position is they can always
surprise you yeah not to break your
queen utterly if there was any example
of why you shouldn't do that this game
seems perfect right all black did was
move around the Queen that's all he did
all game he didn't move any other piece
think about that no other piece of
blocks got moved except for Bishop takes
Knight right and pawns all his pieces
stay in the back ring so do not bring
your queen out early unless you have a
really good reason for it basically
there are exceptions to every rule in
chess I would say but that's one where
you really want to avoid it also the
power of the initiative right if you can
force your opponent to do what you want
if you can attack them if you can keep
attacking them they're far less likely
to do any damage to you and you're
probably going to be controlling the
game which is usually different
you